quand on regarde koh lanta on pense
vivre par procuration la vie des
candidats de l'émission sans filtre
pourtant la production du programme ne
nous cache rethel pas des rapprochements
plus intime entre les candidats une
question qui a été posée sans détour
dans le documentaire la vraie vie de vos
aventuriers diffusée sur ces 8 mardi
soir une question à laquelle tiffany et
andré ont répondu sans détour
physiquement ça invincible on remarque
même pas pourtant on ne peut pas dire
que la production envisage pas des
rapprochements entre les candidats et
fournissent à des déclarations que
d'autres aventuriers comme brice avait
déjà confirmé auparavant
on pense à un gros steak est pas une
paire de fesses lucky qui est resté dans
l'avion avant d'arriver sur l'île
toutefois selon un candidat qui a décidé
de garder l'anonymat qui s'était confié
au parisien tout le monde ne serait pas
en manque de libido sur l'île
il y a bien eu des relations sexuelles
ou amoureuse cela se sait c'est un tout
petit monde
alors pensez vous vraiment que les
candidats de koh lanta n'ont pas de
relations sexuelles pendant l' aventure
alors qu'il ya des infos kerry qui
n'aura pas guillaume à la alors il faut
savoir donc ils peuvent territoire des
relations sexuelles à produire des
préservatifs à disposition en revanche
quand vous prenez pas de douche pendant
42 jours parce que personne n'a de
libido en revanche qu'il faut savoir
c'est qui est une maison pour les
candidats qu'on les candidats viennent
d'être éliminés de l'aventuré et qui
reviennent un peu plus tard ils sont
dans un espèce d'hôtel et là ils peuvent
prendre des douches ils peuvent dormir
ensemble et ils peuvent couché ensemble
et c'est ce que sous-entend d'un peu les
candidats dans le documentaire d'accord
dont il ya eu des choses sur collants il
ya eu des choses dans la maison des
candidats il ya des infos surtout au
début au tout début avant que l'
aventure commence vraiment c'est à dire
le moment où ils arrivent ils ont une
huile sur place ou en toute fin mais
sinon après je vous jure que temps vous
n'avez pas pas vous n'êtes pas laver les
dents pendant 40 jours ça excite pas
prouvé que quand on maigrit trop vite ce
qui est le cas dans koh lanta la libido
est aux abonnés absents a choisi le
bisou et en tue l'amour le nez bouche
est un tue-l'amour l'ail et un tué
l'amour quoi et le nez bouché les
bouchers pourquoi on a du mal à
s'emballer comme le sont c'est un silo
mais on sent pas le fonctionnement de
charcot et donc maigrir vite comme les
candidats ollanta c'est un tueur et bah
c'est à dire qu indique avec quels
déchets on est sûr qu'il y peut rien
bideau des fois c'est vrai à sentir en
plus du candidat qui a témoigné de façon
anonyme il ya des techniciens aussi
qu'ils l'ont dit parce que la nuit ils
ont un oeil et ça va un petit peu ce qui
passe à côté et vous dis
qu'effectivement il y avait eu des
rapports sexuels et denis brogniart a
confirmé en disant et surtout après
l'émission entre les candidats d'accord
c'est bien avant ou après merci ce
qu'elle a dit avant après il ya juste
bernard montiel qui dit non mais lui il
est sur la question sur valéry giscard
d'estaing